security forces in Guatemala blocking a
bridge
who's on the receiving end of the tear
gas and pepper spray are migrants many
of them from Venezuela
this incident took place over the motawa
river a natural border between Guatemala
and Honduras
these people tried to enter the country
but their progress was halted and we're
verifying whether they can prove they
comply with the requirements to enter
the country
these images highlight just some of the
challenges Venezuelan migrants face as
they continue to flee crisis conditions
in their home country
in an effort to reduce record migration
numbers a recent change in U.S policy
enables U.S authorities to expel illegal
Venezuelan refugees to Mexico but allows
some still in Venezuela to fly direct to
the U.S for a period of two years as
long as they secure a sponsor
but these migrants in the Mexican state
of Chiapas are not among the lucky ones
despite the challenges ahead they
continued earlier this week to push
North
we just want to reach our destination
these people here will not stop until
they reach their goal to achieve a dream
that all of us who are walking want to
attain if we need to walk all day and
night until we reach the end we will do
it
we asked Joe Biden to give us an
opportunity because we deserve it
Venezuelans now account for roughly half
of all migrants traveling through Latin
America
and more than 7 million are estimated to
be living as migrants and refugees
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera